I'm 32 are you surprised that I've made
it this far yeah me too
did you chuckle this video yesterday was
my birthday well right now is my
birthday I won't I'm lying I'm already
lying oh no nothing has changed 1 thank
you all for all the birthday wishes
they're really really sweet I don't know
how to take like niceness I don't know
how that process emotions ha like a big
thank you but I thought I would give you
32 things that I have learned over the
last year of my life about myself and
the world at large here we go I wrote
them in the list because I couldn't
remember them I don't have a good memory
I've learned that that's not one that's
on the list it's like just there's a
precursor ok I learned the wrestling is
the most beautiful form of theater of
our generation
second only to medieval times never good
then we take a quick shower and we wash
our hair until we feel like a beautiful
reborn pile of wet cardboard sometimes
it's best to just hire a professional
[Music]
shouldn't be hired to entertain at your
children's birthday parties that require
a face painting dick bags
fun bags and overs don't get easier hi
guys my name is oh I get my makeup
skills from my mother very strong
sensation I feel I should be a cook my
dog sucks at YouTube challenges god damn
it
[Music]
did you just listen so you rather just
lick straight-up metal for over two
solid minutes then participate in the
mannequin challenge yeah you speak for a
lot of us I am great at back tub parties
body Ivanka Trump is sad inside at this
point I finally know how to shotgun a
beer
we put a whole like shake it and put a
hole in it you pop the top and you you
don't shake it
but you like this I thought you like
turn it over like you were librarians
you're gonna book the koi I'm great at
Halloween costumes dude you had dildo
sometimes I revealed too much to my
friends never have I ever been in
handcuffs through criminal purposes but
still my friends don't really know
everything about me what was my dog
deuces original name yeah I forget about
it sometimes cue the internet always
sells very practical items
[Music]
why my friends can handle they're like
oh wait a minute old friend
yeah exes can be friends and they can
talk about seeing other people I can see
my neighbors that's cool I'm not fit for
survival
what are you why are you if I want to
zip it up zip the tin up symbolic or
disgusting about what's happening right
now
halfway to news I'm not into some
internet trends I don't like I shouldn't
be a golfer oh definitely taking
practice swings oh that doesn't count
you never touched the ball doesn't count
you didn't hit it you just turn the
equation into a dip yeah we are you in
such a thousand of them potato I
shouldn't be a drag queen that did
something oh good oh the glue is flaking
off so it looks like I just went dry
skin.he deities this leg sake you're not
a doctor
it shouldn't be allowed in hotel rooms
used on HBO Game of Thrones promotional
pin for this masturbation material it's
free you don't have to panic about
clearing your web browser after you're
done it shouldn't be a daily vlogger and
I'm off to my second meeting of the day
angle change I know it's really uncool
how's your day
ah ah your storage so long he'll jump
cutting your mouth
haha also I love you I love you I love
you I don't know when I said it last I
love you don't the internet with where
it means absolutely nothing like science
or math it's my turn and interesting
personality I've never experienced your
mom my cousin's kind of sucks you
handing out backpacks and t-shirts to
those kids infinitely more charitable
than what a teacher's normal day-to-day
job is for the pay that she gets and the
work that she puts in constantly and
consistently oh you better [ __ ] I'm
awkward the morning after good morning
beautiful
[Music]
-
[Music]
what friends the friends inside my head
[Music]
okay
lastly I don't know thank you guys again
for all of the well wishes and kind
words it's really really sweet and I'm
still processing it because sometimes
I'm a robot make sure you subscribe to
this YouTube channel I make three videos
a week sometimes sometimes they don't
and click that notification so you know
because oh the other thing just a bonus
I'm wildly inconsistent that's something
I definitely learned this year okay get
out of here leave now I'm just petting
your face haha haven't learned personal
space yet maybe a 33